As far as the non-Muslims are concerned,
if the non-Muslim knows what is awaiting
from them in Akara that they're going to
go to hell and a prophet said the least
fire, the least pain if it reaches
your soul, your brains would boil. So if
the non-Muslims know what is awaiting
for them in the next life even if they
the most poorest man in the world they
will think they in Jenna correct because
they know what's going to happen there
you're a little bit hot you know we want
air condition we want this we cannot
stay without it there the least
punishment if the fire touches your soul
your brains would boil imagine So even
the worst human being who's a non-Muslim
would consider this as paradise.
[snorts] So this is the explanation of
the hadith of the prophet of Sai Muslim
volume number 7 had number 7417.
The glorious Quran
the last and final revelation of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala. It has the solutions
for the problem of humanity.
[clears throat] If it is a revelation
and last and final and after that no
other revelation will come. One of the
requirement is it should have the
solution for the problems of humankind.
And the glorious Quran
it is the solution for the problems of
humankind. It is the furan
it is the criteria to judge right from
wrong. The glorious Quran has the
solution for racism. Allah says in surah
chapter number 49 verse number 13.
Oh humankind, we have created you from a
single pair of male and female and have
divided you into nations and tribes so
that you shall recognize each other not
that you shall despise each other. And
the most honored in the sight of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala is the person who
has tawa. The criteria for judgment in
the sight of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala,
it's not color, it is not age, it's not
wealth, it's not sex, it's not race, it
is tawa, it's God consciousness, it's
piety.
So Islam has the solution for racism.
Islam has the solution of terrorism. One
verse of the Quran is sufficient to
prove that Islam
is against terrorism and has the
solution for terrorism. Allah says in
surah maida chapter number 5 verse
number 32. If anyone kills a human being
unless it be for murder or for spreading
corruption in the land it is as though
he has killed the whole of humanity.
Allah says if any human being whether
Muslim or non-Muslim kills any other
human being whether Muslim or non-Muslim
unless it be for murder or for spreading
corruption it is as though he has killed
the whole of humanity. And the verse
continues, if anyone saves any other
human being, whether Muslim or
non-Muslim, it is as though he has saved
the whole of humanity. So this one verse
of the Quran is sufficient to solve the
problem of terrorism.
Quran
has the solution
for inequality, for injustice. Allah
says in surah 4 verse number 135
that
oh you believe stand out for justice as
witness to Allah subhanana wa ta'ala
even if it be against yourself against
your relatives against your mother or
father against your parents whether they
be rich or poor Allah protects all so
when you are giving witness to Allah
subhananaa irrespective whether the
witness will go against yourself against
your parents against your relatives the
rich For the poor, Allah protects all.
Quran has the solution for alcoholism
and drug addiction. Allah says in the
Quran in Surah Maida chapter number 5
verse number 19,
oh you believe most certainly
intoxicated and gambling
dedication of stones, divation of
arrows.
Please accept this handwork.
Abstain from this handwork that you may
prosper. So the solution for alcoholism
is it is prohibited. It's haram.